>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Edward Widner: Good
afternoon everyone.
Welcome to LJ119.
My name's Ted Widner.
I'm the director of the
John W. Kluge Center.
And if you grew up in New England
like I did, this time of year,
April 19th -- specifically
the night of April 18th
to 19th is the night some of
us remember as the outbreak
of hostilities in 1775 and
switched to a military phase
of the long conflict between
the colonies and Great Britain.
It's now sort of developed into
just a marathon and a lot of parties
around Boston, and not too many
people remember the political
circumstances of April 1775.
But I can guarantee you, one person
in this room knows
them very, very well.
It's such a pleasure to introduce
to you T.H. Breen of Timothy Breen,
who is the John Kluge
professor of American law
and governance here
at the Kluge Center.
He's also the William Smith
Mason Professor Emeritus
at Northwestern University.
He's the James Marsh Professor at
large, at the University of Vermont,
and that is -- that has to be the
greatest job anyone could ever have
to be a Professor at Large and
that is what he's been for us.
He's covered the waterfront.
He's been inspiring presence
among us at our lunches
and in the hallway,
striking up conversations.
The Kluge Center has a lot of
different kinds of scholars
in different disciplines
and Timothy's been just a
wonderful addition to our mix.
Many of you know his work already.
Many of you are personal
friends of his,
and it's delightful to
welcome you all here.
I can't possibly list his productive
output because it would take
up most of the next hour.
He's the author of
more than 60 articles.
Many, many books, the most recent
one of which is a favorite of mine,
George Washington's Journey
, which came out in 2014.
In 2010, American Insurgence .
In 2005, The Marketplace
of Revolution:
How Consumers Shaped
American Independence .
in 2003, Colonia Americans
in an Atlantic World .
1985, Tobacco Culture .
1980, Puritan's and Adventurer's .
1970, The Character
of a Good Rule .
And that's not even all of them,
and I'm already out of breath.
In all this work he's
done political history,
economic history, social history.
He's written about
the Colonial north,
he's written about
the Colonial south,
he's written about everything.
And it's just been a great
personal pleasure for me,
as someone very interested
in this period,
to spend these last
few months with him.
I'm looking forward not
only to his talk today,
but I'm really looking forward
to his review of the new Museum
of the American Revolution that
opened in Philadelphia this week.
He's covering it as a
journalist reviewing it
for The New York Review of Books .
And I think, thinking about it as
a journalist and as someone living
in the present is part of the way
Timothy Breen thinks about events
that we are still dealing
with on a daily basis.
Its history, but it's
still effecting us
and we have new institutions
springing
up with new interpretations.
And thank god he's here to make
sense out of it for the rest of us.
So without further ado, please
welcome Timothy H. Breen.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Breen: Thank you Ted,
and all of his staff and helpers
who have made the last four
months if nothing else,
extraordinarily productive.
I mean, to work in the Library of
Congress means I even imagine a book
and it's on my desk the next day.
It's an incredible resource.
And so it's coming to
the end, but my wife
and I have really enjoyed being here
and I thank all of
you on this hot day.
I might say just in passing, the new
Museum of the American Revolution
that opened yesterday in
Philadelphia is very good.
I'm not going to trash
it in my article.
I thought I would.
I went there with that goal.
But progress and intelligence has
betrayed me, and I came away feeling
that this is an important
contribution
to our shared understanding
of what the revolution
means for our country.
I come 19th Century
Irish background.
Not part of the American Revolution,
and yet the American
Revolution is all of our realm.
I mean, it created our political
system for better or worse.
I think better some days.
But there you are.
The -- my comments today
will be woven someway --
I'm not quite clear, into a book
that I'm writing, I
was researching here.
And it's called An Appeal to
Heaven , which was the major slogan
of the American revolutionaries,
certainly in the first
-- 1775 and 6.
So it's An Appeal to Heaven:
The American Revolution .
And this book proposes to
address several questions.
My paper today won't
address all of these,
but I certainly will
entertain questions.
One of the oldest questions is
still out there and that is,
what was revolutionary about
the American Revolution?
At the end of the day
that's still a problem.
Second, how did ordinary people --
men and women living in small
communities from Georgia
to New Hampshire --
experience the revolution?
Not as soldiers, but as members
of small communities sustaining
and mobilizing, and re-mobilizing
a revolution that succeeded --
in fact, the book will
argue that although most
of our attention still is on
the great leaders of the time,
and maybe on the battlefields --
like NFL plays, you follow
the little marches around.
It's all important.
I'm not denigrating that.
But if it hadn't been for small
towns that never saw the face
of war -- that sustained the
revolution -- we would not have won.
I mean it was the people
who got behind the cause
and keep the cause alive.
And third, is a question
that developed in the course
of my research here, and that is how
did a war that generated such hate,
such bitterness, a sense of
revenge, anger, domestic enemies --
your neighbors could have killed
your family or destroyed your farm.
There was hostility in the
land, and yet at the end
of the American Revolution it ended.
Unlike almost every other
revolution we can think of,
our revolution stopped and
there was not killing fields
or massive sense of
revenge in the land.
I think that's something
needs to be explained.
Not in order to praise us as
an exceptional revolution,
but as a problematic in
comparing our revolution
with other revolutions
throughout the war.
Like a good undergraduate teacher
I have a crude handout some
of you have I hope.
I always praise the crudity
of my handouts because I claim
that it's more authentic --
its like more revolutionary.
It was neat, you see, you
wouldn't -- it wouldn't be proper.
So, at the start -- and let me just
read my comments as best I can,
and welcome your questions.
Let me warn you in advance that
this is a very radical presentation,
and if you want to leave now
or you're going to be offend --
it's a triggering moment.
Right? You're going to
hear some radical things.
Rest assured, I'm not proposing
anything wildly conspiratorial
such as that George Washington
was really a secret agent
for the British Parliament or
that the founding fathers wanted
to redistribute land and
property to the peasants
in the name of worker equality.
Rather drawing on the research
that I've been pursuing here
at the center, thanks
to Ted and his friends,
I want to interrogate closely
a revolutionary narrative
that Americans -- all
of us I think --
have been telling ourselves about
the nature of the nations origins.
The process of reconsidering the
relationship between chronology
and narrative, between
the assumptions about time
and its effect on causality
raises for me at least, exciting,
even radical new questions
about the fundamental character
of the American Revolution.
Now even to pose the question --
as I have in the title
of the lecture --
what time was the American
Revolution --
may strike you as slightly perverse
since in fact the temporal
boundaries of revolution
from the initial colonial
grievances to the achievement
of political stability under the
federal constitution have been well
established in the historical memory
of the United States
for several centuries.
But however persuasive
this narrative may be,
recent and ongoing research
invites a thorough rethinking
of the familiar account.
Although some scholars
once traced the origins
of the American Revolution
back to the dark forrest
of ancient Germany --
they really did that.
And others have insisted that the
American Revolution did not realize
its full revolutionary potential
until the age of Jackson.
The story of our national origins --
think of third grade
again in your life --
most often begins with the
1760 coronation of George III
and then step by step it traces
the growth of colonial unrest
from resistance to the Stamp
Act, through the Boston Massacre,
the Tea Party, the Battle of
Bunker Hill, and then the drafting
of the Declaration of Independence.
After this defining moment
in 1776, the standard litany
of events loses some of its clarity
and many historians have leapt
with interpretive grace
from the Declaration
of Independence all the
way to the Constitution.
I call this the lily pad or
the frog pond theory of leaping
from one event to another event.
Of course this traditional approach
of time and narrative works best
with intellectual history
or the story of history
of political thought, since the
development of abstract concepts
such as virtue and liberty
often does not concern itself
with the changes social
and political context
of the events on the ground.
To be sure, a revolutionary
narrative framed by the accession
of George III and the ratification
of the Constitution does possess
a kind of compelling logic.
It allows us to navigate
a smooth interpretive path
from national liberation
to political stability.
This traditional periodization
however,
raises a troublesome
interpretive challenge.
The standard narratives
suggest be it implicitly a kind
of inevitability of
celebratory chronicle
of the American people marching
forward under the banner of liberty
and rights to their
well deserved destiny
as citizens of the New Republic.
Not surprisingly, this complacent
story lends itself to organic,
even providential metaphors.
You know them.
Children growing up and demanding
that the mother country
treat them with respect.
Or colonies growing to maturity like
political plants until they flower
in the form of political
independence.
From these perspectives,
the temporal flow
of crucial events acquires
a kind of causal aspect,
becoming in the telling a
coherent teleological tale
in which one thing leads necessarily
to another thing from
beginning to end.
The description of the nations
origins therefore often takes a kind
of self-congratulatory tone.
One grounded on the assumption
of American exceptionalism.
A belief that our revolution,
this revolution was
somehow different, special.
Even unique.
Unlike other revolutions that
have shaped the modern world.
In this rendering there's
not much incentive to engage
in a comparative analysis.
In other words, to examine
whether the American revolutionary
experience over time
paralleled in interesting ways
that of other nations
throughout the world.
The French Revolution.
The Haitian Revolution.
The Russian Revolution.
What is at stake in
posing a question
about revolutionary time therefore,
is the possibility, the invitation,
the excitement of developing
a less teleological,
more coherent understanding of the
relationship between interpretation,
periodization, and narrative.
The alternative conceptualization
of revolutionary time that I want
to advance here is that what
we now think of generally
as the single essentially
monolithic block of time --
a block of time roughly
from 1760 to 1788 --
should in fact be three
discrete segments.
Each demanding its own interpretive
standing in the flow of time.
I bring to bear evidence number one.
You can look, you can follow.
You see the block of
time and now through it.
It'll be on the final exam.
So pay attention.
This revised perspective does
not start with the assumption
that history is moving
towards a predestined goal
such as greater democracy,
or more personal freedom,
or a powerful American empire.
Rather my argument
begins with the assertion
that the period most often
associated with the run
up to the revolution and the
Declaration of Independence --
in other words, the period 1760 to
1773 -- was nothing of the sort.
These years are more accurately
defined as a general crisis
of imperial rule throughout
the Atlantic world.
The relatively minor provincial
risings in the American colony --
the Stamp Act crisis, the Boston
Massacre, the destruction of the tea
in Boston harbor, lets face
it, were really minor tremors
in an ongoing effort by an ambitious
imperial power to make sense
of the unprecedented
challenge of governing peoples,
of different races, and of different
backgrounds, and of different places
over a vast world in which
communication remained slow
and unreliable.
The second stage -- the second
new stage of this revised version
of revolutionary time begins in
1774 with the military occupation
of Boston and ends with
the Peace Treaty of 1783.
A period during which a colonial
rebellion -- colonial rebellion --
transformed itself into a genuine
political and social revolution.
It involved the experience of
armed resistance, of large numbers
of ordinary people suddenly
assuming meaningful authority
for the first time in
communities throughout American,
and of social relations that were
no longer defined by monarchy
or aristocratic relationships.
These developments
promoted a strong sense
of republic equality among
white males that turned itself
into initial armed response against
monarchical authority and eventually
into a revolution few people
wanted or anticipated in 1776.
The third period -- again,
look at your chart --
in this revised narrative is the
years following the end of the war.
Did not lead inevitably
to the Constitution,
the federal constitution.
Divorce from the traditional
triumph discourse --
of which we all know we should
see the period after 1770 --
1783 as a post-revolutionary moment
in which ordinary people came
to terms with life under an
experimental federal regime
and as they did so,
they sought to reabsorb
into an uncertain civil society
a large number of Americans
who had recently sided
with Great Britain.
To depict this decade of the
1780's as "the critical period" --
that's what it's called
in most books --
it focuses unwarranted attention on
elite fears of disorder and anarchy
and by so doing, turns an explosion
of entrepreneurial energy
among ordinary men and women
into an alarming account of a
revolution betrayed at the moment
of it's greatest success.
So let me explain a little bit the
rationale for this new narrative.
And Ted, do you have
a whip or something?
A prod if I go.
A radical recasting of
revolutionary chronology begins
with a thorough reassessment
of the period before 1775.
These years seem especially
vulnerable
to teleological interpretation.
One can easily understand
the temptation to anticipate
in the years, the coming of
revolution and independence.
Because we know -- we know what's
coming and it appear only fair
from this perspective to depict
every event as a harbinger
to the final break with
Great Britain, but even armed
with the clarity of hindsight
there's no reason to conclude
that local complaints about
imperial rule, even urban riots,
even threats of organized
resistance amounted to any more
than what they were, highly limited
protests that lost the potential
for a large scale mobilization
within days or months
of their initial occurrence.
Such episodes hardly
represented a serious break
with imperial authority.
Throughout the 18th Century the
British showed remarkable ability
to maintain order in
England, Scotland, Ireland.
The negotiations in this empire
usually involved a pragmatic mixture
or carrots and sticks, and
at the end of the day even
when lethal violence was employed,
the narrative process successfully
re-channeled local anger.
For example, the bloody conclusion
of the Massacre at St. George Fields
in London in a tense 1768.
There were at least seven people
brought down by government troops.
About the same as the
Boston Massacre.
But this was not a sign that the
British people were conspiring
to launch a revolution?
Conditions in North American
colonies were not that .
The Boston Massacre certainly did
not lead inevitably to Bunker Hill
or the Declaration of Independence.
Instead, the event introduced
three years of extraordinary peace.
1770 to 1773 were the most
peaceful, consumer oriented years
of the whole colonial period.
And poor Sam Adams was in
utter despair in his ability
to persuade the people that
they had legitimate grievances
against the empire.
No doubt, Parliament's
attempts during the 1760's
to raise revenue -- stamps, sugar,
tea -- irritated the Americans,
especially those that
lived in the port cities.
But, the fact of the matter is
that those Boston agitators even
at the height of the Stamp Act
crisis did not receive much support
from the ordinary people
living in other parts
of the British American colonies.
Leaders of the colonial
assemblies wrote
to other leaders of
colonial assemblies.
They talked about possible coercion,
about making stamp collectors
resign, but that was about it.
Even in Massachusetts town meetings
in the countryside
showed little enthusiasm
for an agenda of the
Boston radicals.
And I can say I've gone through all
the town records and they're still
in print of these towns
of Massachusetts,
and outside of Boston there was a
big yawn about what those wackos
in Boston were up to in 1765.
So the ability to limit and control
occasional controversy is precisely
what one would have
expected at the time.
Even if there had been
no revolution.
After all, the American colonists
viewed the victory over the French
in the Seven Years War as
incontrovertible evidence
of their American loyalty
to the empire.
And by their own lives,
they were not full partners
in a powerful expanding
imperial regime.
In so much, as the Americans
experienced a growing sense
of nationalism after the
war, the expressed it
in almost a reflective emotional
attachment to Great Britain.
Indeed, many historians call
this phenomena I think rightly,
the sense of colonial nationalism.
What then, you might say -- should
there be any critics out there --
of the much quoted pamphlets
that drive the standard account
of the American -- the
coming of the revolution?
Surely like the prophets
of the Old Testament,
they were preparing the way.
But in fact, celebrated
writers such as John Adams
and John Dickinson were not
harolds of an independent republic.
The colonists who analyzed the
American grievances were members
of a creole elite.
In other words, a group of wealthy,
privileged, well-educated men
who felt themselves marginalized
within the imperial structure.
That was their problem.
Not enough patronage
is going our way.
What these ambitious
Americans wanted was --
lets put it bluntly -- respect.
To be accepted by the leading
British political figures
as fully British and
not as lesser beings
who inhabited the marshlands
of empire.
George Washington sulked when he
was not given a proper commission
in the British Army.
John Adams looking to
make a political --
or legal career in
Massachusetts complained bitterly
that Hutchison's clan
got all the business,
and he had not received
any imperial patronage.
Protesting his imagined inferiority
in British eyes, Adams announced,
I say we are as handsome
as English folks here
and therefore should be free.
James Otis agreed.
Benjamin Franklin held out
in the hope of acceptance
to the very eve of revolution.
It was only when he was humiliated
during a public hearing in London
that he finally decided that
Philadelphia was his home.
Creole leaders were not
plotting revolution.
They only wanted to be
accepted in the imperial club.
Frances Bernard -- a royal governor
of Massachusetts during
the 1760's --
a very smart and misunderstood
man --
understood how to accommodate
these upity colonials.
And he advised the Earl
of Hillsborough in 1769
that if Parliament would only
create a kind of upper house
in each colony, a kind of
American House of Lords filled
with wealthy Americans appointed
by the King, it would --
and I quote Bernard -- go a
long way to remedy the disorders
to which the government
of America is subject to.
And he predicted --
I think correctly --
that eager Americans would fall
all over themselves to have --
and I quote again -- Barron
prefixed to their name.
The beauty of the change
would be that in the addition
of so many royal honors from the
new form of govern, it will assist
in the establishment of it by
engaging men who are ripe for honors
to reconciling the
people to the system
that introduces the new honors.
Nothing came with the plan.
Since in fact parliamentary leaders
did look at the Americans as well
as the Irish, as well as the
Scots, as inferior subjects.
That's true.
But bias here threatened what
could have been a brilliant reform
to save the empire.
What once appeared as
simply the inevitable run
up to the American
Revolution therefore takes
on a very different
character when we view it
as a crisis within the empire.
Great Britain was not
alone in having troubles
with demanding creole leaders.
Throughout the new world
they demanded more authority.
They demanded a meaningful
voice in the Atlantic economy.
This was the moment when
the British, the French,
and the Spanish discovered for the
first time that they were not fully
in control of the lands and
the peoples of the new world
that they claimed to rule.
The new world remained
uncharted territory
for these imperial administrators.
And awareness of this demanding,
fluent, fluid experimental aspect
of 18th Century expansion I think
erodes our standard revolutionary
narrative and indeed it brings us
into an unprecedented
imperial crisis.
And reminds us that the
pre-revolutionary period was not
pre-revolutionary at all.
It was rather a period of sorting
out complex relations, races,
distances, peoples
throughout a territory
that amounted to half the globe.
The second, even more
significant break
in the standard revolutionary
time in 1774.
This was a crucial year.
This was the major year that
witnessed the rendering of time,
rendering of the old narrative
we all learned in third grade.
For although memories of an
earlier period shaped the political
consensus of consciousness
of Americans the landscape
of power underwent a
sudden and profound shift.
And the trigger for massive change
was not the traditional story
of the coming of the American
Revolution, the Boston Tea Party.
It was not the Boston Tea Party.
Many Americans saw the destruction
of the private property in Boston
as an extreme and unpleasant
form of protest.
As an unwarranted provocation.
An attack on property.
And there was in fact almost no
outpouring of popular support
for the people of Boston
who organized throwing
the tea into the water.
What fundamentally and irrevocably
transformed the character
of colonial politics was not
the destruction of the tea,
but the reaction in Parliament
to the destruction of the tea.
The story of protest by creole
leaders suddenly became a tale
of massive popular mobilization.
And so in 1774 we enter an entirely
new, unprecedented political world.
Lord North and his
allies passed a series
of harsh retaliatory acts
known as the Coercive Acts,
which not only closed the Port
of Boston to all commerce,
but more important -- and
I think we overlook --
authorized armed military occupation
of the second largest
city in colonial America.
I might say that the Brits had
never used armed occupation
in their own cities under --
this was a provocation of
great, great magnitude.
And for the colonists
living is distant places
such as South Carolina and Virginia,
the British punishments seemed
totally out of proportion
with the seriousness of the crime.
Over night, British -- over night
Boston became a city occupied
by a standing army and it's
subjects subject to marshal law.
And suddenly in that year, you find
Americans -- ordinary Americans,
men and women -- talking about
something called the American cause.
A new phrase in the
lexicon of protest.
The revisionary view
of revolutionary time
that I'm proposing takes our
attention away from the writings
of celebrated leaders, the ones --
the pamphlets, the arguments
of lawyers and planters.
My time restores the people who
actually showed up at Bunker Hill
and figured out what revolution
meant in their lives without having
to read the learned pamphlets
that figure so centrally
in our intellectual history.
One detail -- and I know there's
an Irishman way back there --
one detail I just want to give you
that shall we say, puts on the alert
about the standard
teleological account, my research
and the research of other scholars
have shown there was a massive flood
of Irish immigrants -- massive --
in 1774, 75, into the
American colonies.
They were driven out of Ireland
-- mostly in the North --
by British restrictions on the linen
industry that were very similar
to the restrictions on
American stamps and so on.
My point was, these Irishmen came
to America and had no experience
or memory of the American
protest of the 1760's.
They were irritated -- they
knew to hate Brits on their own.
They didn't need the
American experience.
So what does it matter?
Research has found that in
some of the continental lines
in Pennsylvania especially, over 60%
of all the fighting men
were new Irish immigrants.
Hm-mm, so much for the teleological
argument about growing protests.
It's the new men, angry
at the empire.
Now 1775, these protests
or this resistance did not signal
the start of a genuine revolution.
That came later.
At first, most American's
hoped that Lord North
and his supporters would simply
come to their senses and find a way
to negotiate a way
to save the empire.
They wanted reform,
not independence.
And there was little
-- almost no enthusiasm
for Republican government.
From this perspective almost
all Americans in 1776 --
75 I would say -- were loyalists.
All of them.
They simply wanted the
British to back down
and restore an imperial system
that would bring them security
and respect within the empire.
Thomas Jefferson noted in
something that you all should read,
because its kind of
a weird document,
and that is the first draft of
the Declaration of Independence.
It's a testimony to good teaching.
I mean, we all think
it's so well written,
but it's took his colleagues
to cut the adverbs
and the adjectives out
and make it pretty.
What did he write at this moment
of the second period of time?
We might have been a free and great
people together, but a communication
of grandeur and of freedom it
seems is below the British dignity.
In so, so they will have
it so, the road to glory
and happiness is open to us.
We will climb it as a separate
state and acquiesce in the necessity
which pronounces us to say to
Britain, an everlasting ado.
That got cut out.
At the start of the war, therefore
the American insurgence clashed
over strategies of
reconciliation and not
over fundamental political ideas.
Even colonial leaders who later
opposed independence [inaudible]
at the beginning of resistance
values such as virtue and liberty.
By 1776, our protest against the
British oppression had begun --
that had begun as a colonial
rebellion comparative to India
or Nigeria, or other
former colonial states.
It had become a real revolution.
The transformation did
not involve the shift
in fundamental political principles.
Ideology did not turn
rebellion into revolution.
After all, the idea that the people
are the only legitimate source
of political power has a very
long history reaching back
into the Middle Ages.
The new element in the time equation
was experienced quite simply
by living through a time of
violent political change.
It was one -- it's one thing
to discuss with your friends
in the pub rights and equality in
the abstract, but quite another
to experience newly formed groups,
army groups, committees of safety
and inspection that recruited
people that had never served
in any political movement at all.
Participation in political
resistance created fresh and new
and exciting emotional bonds
that carried radical potential.
White American males came to believe
in a crude sense their equality.
Aristocratic claims to special
privilege no longer counted
for much.
Achievement through works
suddenly transcended the old order.
That's revolutionary in
the late-18th Century.
To be sure, the language of rights
inspired American revolutionaries.
The traditional story of
revolution stresses the centrality
of these enabling principles they
did yesterday in Philadelphia.
But that approach discounts
other binding elements,
some of which make
modern commentators
on our revolution uncomfortable.
The actual experience of war
included not only Republican ideas,
but also a forgotten lexicon of
unsettled words such as fear,
vengeance, retaliation,
denunciation,
betrayal, revenge, and violence.
That's part of our revolution too.
It is this emotionally
charged political environment
that has gone missing from
the historical literature,
securing the revolution -- securing
our revolution was difficult
and dangerous for all people.
Suspicion of neighbors, enforcing
the revolutionary agenda,
taking property from domestic
enemies, is often thought as a part
of the story of other revolutions.
Less nice, less good
revolutions than ours.
But I can assure you it was a
nasty business those eight years.
After the victory of Yorktown,
Americans entered the third
and final, and blessedly
for you, short period.
Which is best described I think
as our post-revolutionary period.
This different terminology
post-revolutionary,
deflects our attention away from the
absolute obsession with the coming
and the drafting of
the Constitution.
George Washington, Andrew
Hamilton, James Madison,
the dominant characters
in the campaign
to establish a strong
central government --
certainly they did worry about the
dangers of political fragmentation.
They became so anxious about the
threat of stability that in fact
that they greatly exaggerated the
danger posed by small agrarian riots
such as Daniel Shays -- a
group of impoverished veterans
in Massachusetts that presents
absolutely no military threat
to anybody, but it
became a national incident
of great historical power
in our story of stealth.
But however we may
admire [inaudible],
we do not have to accept
this analysis.
If one concentrates chiefly on
elite fears, on looming anarchy
as most American historians
have done,
one discounts the buoyant optimism
that characterized the
American people as whole.
There's not much evidence that
they were paralyzed by anxiety
over the country's future.
The revolution in itself
unleashed an extraordinary burst
of energy and optimism.
Suddenly after years of
British economic regulation,
ordinary Americans devised schemes
everywhere to better their lives.
Build a canal, speculate
on land, a new mill,
new people were participating
in fresh and exciting,
and free ways in a growing economy.
And they moved west in huge numbers.
Probably the worst
thing that ever happened
to the Native American
people's on this continent.
But they did.
Like locusts they moved west
and started new lives
and took up new farms.
And they had lots and
lots of children.
The greatest percentage of
population growth in the history
of the United States
occurred in the 1780's
and it is almost not traceable to
migration from foreign country.
Men and women are having kids
because they're optimistic
about the future of their country.
They are not sitting around saying,
oh we need a strong
federal government.
Where's the -- where should we go?
To Philadelphia?
The rejection of the
standard narrative,
a smooth almost predestined tale of
gifted leaders guiding the people
from colonial protest to political
stability, therefore brings
into fresh focus and new
challenging concerns.
And to me, the payoff seems obvious.
First, the years before
1774 become part
of a genuinely imperative
world story
about imperial rivalries
throughout the Atlantic world.
The competition for military
and commercial dominance shaped
the lives of ordinary Europeans
and African slaves, as well
as indigenous people's.
Second, an account of the
actual experience of living
through a revolution
restores ordinary people
to a tale previously dominated
by a group of leaders.
It liberates us from the
obsession on the founding fathers
and gives genuine agency to
the people in the creation
of their own new republic.
And third, by rejecting
the teleological account
of the Constitution as
almost providential,
restores our appreciation of a surge
of popular entrepreneurial energy
that generated excitement in
a post-revolutionary society.
The new periodization of
revolution -- here I pause it --
is dynamic, its open to the people
who did not pen founding documents
or serve as generals or statesmen.
And so, in a surge for a
more textured, more complex,
more inclusive, more
comparative revolution it is time
that we all ask ourselves, what
time was the American Revolution?
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
That was a wonderful talk.
I've learned a great deal from it.
I've asked a number
of people as a test,
what gave rise to the
Boston Tea Party?
Almost invariably say, well the
British increased the taxes.
But I gather in fact, it
was almost the opposite,
that people like Sam Adams were
smuggling tea from Holland,
undercutting the British
and the British dropped the
export tax to be more competitive.
Now it may be more
complicated than that,
but I'd like to know
what your views are.
>> Timothy Breen: No,
you're absolutely right.
Even though I was fearful that your
accent would lead to an attack,
in point of fact, the tea act
would have lowered the price
for the consumer.
What the Americans said
is lower price or not,
it's still a tax that
we didn't vote on.
And so it's on principle
not acceptable.
But I don't -- but again,
my point was all that aside,
it was the British reaction
sending General Gage and thousands
of soldiers to Boston and closing
Massachusetts to all commerce,
and closing all town meetings
that by then had a 200 year
history of self-government.
It's exactly the same thing --
I'm looking at my Irish
friend back there.
It's exactly the same thing the
Brits after the Eastern rising.
The Easter rising, most Irish
people felt were a bunch
of nutters, you know.
And they probably were.
But it was the execution day after
day after day, and the humiliation
of the Irish people that turned
a weak protest into a rebellion.
Same thing happened here.
Nut cases were made
martyrs to the people.
Yes? He's going to give
you a speaker dinger.
>> At the beginning of your lecture
you raised the intriguing question
of how Americans coped
with reabsorbing those
who had been the enemies within
in the wake of the revolution.
>> Timothy Breen: Yeah.
>> And I wonder if you could
say a little about that
and your conclusions on that.
>> Timothy Breen: Okay.
Thank you very much for --
because that's what I spent the
last four months studying here
at the library and now Ted will
think he got his money's worth.
It is cited probably
impressionistically
that about 60,000 Americans left
at the end of the war and went
to Nova Scotia or other places,
sometimes to the Caribbean.
And of that group, a huge
number were not eager to go,
because they were the slaves
owned by these people.
So whatever the number is.
But the research that I've done
shows that the great majority
of people that had participated
as enemies of the revolution
in some demonstrable way either
giving aid and comfort to the enemy
or perhaps even serving in
one of their loyalist legions,
far exceeded, far, far
exceeded that 60,000 number.
And this set off a very forgotten --
thankfully it's forgotten
because now I can write my book --
but the first rate
refugee crisis in America.
Because these people that had
been enemies of the revolution --
and some of them had done
some very bad things --
they wanted to come home.
They wanted to live with their
neighbors they had violated,
and humiliated, and hurt.
And the ordinary people
of American said, no way.
No way.
It was the leaders and the people
that signed the peace treaty
in Paris that said -- as all
political documents like this,
the language is very wishy washy --
but that Congress of the
United States would recommend
to the separate state governments
that they would not pursue loyalists
or any other people who had
acted against the interests
of the United States
before the peace treaty.
The people were not happy to
hear this and there were many,
many incidents of local violence.
The Sons of Liberty, which
we associate with the lead
up to the revolution
reformed in Boston in 1783
to keep the refugees out.
But in time -- by 1786 remarkably --
I think people -- they wanted farms,
they wanted to go west,
they wanted to say hello
to all these kids they're having.
Whatever they did, the hatred
dissipated, and so it's true
that for instance,
some of the leaders
in the Washington cabinet
were Tories.
They had, you know, come back.
Trench Cocks is one
economic analysis.
The point is for a concatenation
of elements in our country --
and I think probably
it was its size.
Because what happened to the Tories?
My answer is usually -- and
it's very glib -- is Ohio.
But people found other things
to do than pursue revenge.
If I may -- I don't think --
I'll maybe end with a story
I found in my research here.
Some of the hottest, my physical
violent, horrible crimes of neighbor
against neighbor took place
in the American south.
Georgia, South Carolina,
especially up country Carolina.
There's a town there that some
of you may have gone
to called Ninety-six.
People think I'm making it up,
but it is a town and it's 96 miles
from Charleston on the
old Indian trade road.
Ninety-six had some bad
times during the war.
And there was a man that
had created real havoc
who had the interesting
name of Matthew Love.
That was the last thing
I'd associate
with Matthew, because
he was a killer.
But the war ended and the
peace treaty was announced
and he showed back up in Ninety-six.
Said, I'm here guys.
Back home.
The locals said, oh boy.
They locked him up in jail and they
waited for the judge to come up --
because there was -- judge's
rode circuit in South Carolina --
came up and it was Judge Grimke.
You may recognize the name because
he had two interesting daughters
who protested slavery on
the coming of the Civil War.
Judge Grimke read to
the jury a statement.
He said, look we hate this guy.
This guy did some really bad
things, but they were war crimes
and this war and this people are not
authorized to deal with war crimes.
That's another world.
We're a new world.
We're new South, we
have our own laws
and there's nothing we
can do with Matthew Love.
And he wrote in his little diary,
he said, the people listened.
They were so attentive.
It was like a civics
lesson, you see.
They said, oh yeah, right.
We have war times and now times.
And they all took the Judge
Grimke back to the local hotel.
Probably had a drink or
two, and he went to bed.
And the people of 96 marched back to
the jail and executed Matthew Love.
And that moment resolved
the tension.
That was -- for these people
that was the end of the --
that was the end of the war.
It wasn't a mass killing,
but there were limits.
And then they found -- yes?
>> Well thank you for the
wonderful revisionist account.
But I was hoping you would
answer your own question.
Namely, most revolutions
have similar beginnings.
But the American Revolution had,
as you pointed out, a
rather unique ending.
A very successful ending.
And so this [inaudible]
revolutionary optimism,
how do we explain it and why
every other revolution ends
in terror, in [inaudible] regimes.
And so what made it possible then?
This positive revolutionary success.
Even before the Constitution,
before Philadelphia.
>> Timothy Breen: I mean, if
you do the standard count its
like I know you study
religious history, whatnot.
You know, its like the standard
New Testament account, you know,
what books are written about.
And we tell ourselves the story
of these wonderful leaders
who were worried about anarchy
and lead us to stability.
That's the answer.
You know, we have a Constitution.
The fact that it's one of the most
undemocratic documents you can
possibly read is beside the point.
My -- I just think that
there were elements,
mostly the [inaudible] come to
think that a much maligned historian
of the late-19th Century --
Turner -- the Turner Thesis.
You know, he said that
basically [inaudible].
Boy, it makes a lot
of sense to me now.
People rushing to Kentucky,
and Ohio, and Indiana,
and reinventing themselves and
finding new ways to make money.
They're not pretty.
You know, this is capitalism
without control.
I understand all that.
But they were following a different
tangent of their lives and because
of the distances out
there it made it very hard
to have these post-revolutionaries
[inaudible] with France
or Haiti never had a
good day [inaudible].
>> [Inaudible].
The very experience of [inaudible].
What ended the revolution
is [inaudible].
So it is unique.
[Inaudible].
>> Timothy Breen: I know,
and I said I didn't want
to have an exceptionalism
view and I don't.
But I've kind of fallen
into it beside myself.
Almost anybody who
witnessed American society
in the 1790's, the
Jeffersonian period.
[Inaudible] was right.
He was a good observer.
I don't like him, but
he was a good observer.
He said, you know, these
Americans they have a problem,
what do they do?
They form a committee.
They have a group.
You know, they don't turn to the
government to solve their problems.
And since they came
out of the revolution
that was genuine heritage
of the revolution.
A mind experiment that's
very interesting, you know,
is that much of what is
seen in the literature
of the revolution today --
and I won't name historians.
They're all wonderful and good.
And that is that America
became more democratic,
more open, more inclusive.
And so, what everyone thinks
of those rolly polly world --
Andrew Jackson -- that's the
American Revolution working
itself out.
Right? But lets say the
revolution hadn't occurred.
How much of what we see
as revolutionary would
have happened anyway?
I mean is Canada a [inaudible]
that we had to avoid?
No. I mean these -- England
is giving the Irish the vote
for god sake.
I mean these things are in the air.
So what a lot of elements
that we say are part
of our revolutionary heritage
would have happened anyway.
All right, I'm finished.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.